so you know you just broke the internet
with the news that the matrix is
happening again
have you read a script yeah and are you
happy with where neo is where would you
like to see me yeah no absolutely it's
very ambitious you know we're all
excited you've been very low-key about
it we're all geeked about this aren't
you geeked about this it was a family
affair Tuesday night in Hollywood as
Keanu Reeves stepped out to support his
sister Corina Millar at the premiere of
the new film she produced Semper Fi
I need you to be my dad I just need you
to be my brother I'm gonna break him out
what are you talking about man I don't
need anything from you guys I wanted to
let you know
congratulations finally getting this
completed and ready for everyone to see
it or you have you exhaled yet no I'm
definitely holding my breath it's been
like three years but they've been trying
to make it for ten so protein thing is
lovely that you're coming out and
supporting your system yeah it's really
awesome to be here and to be invited
it's such a great accomplishment and
it's a wonderful film and so how is that
yeah he's coming to kind of be the side
of the arm piece no he's always been so
supportive and so protective of me doing
my own thing and that I always really
appreciate so and it's fun family here
because our mom it's not a challenge go
has this bond have you guys always had
this really close bond growing up I'm 12
years younger than he is so when he was
doing like teenage that I was in diapers
so but we're catching up to ask this
question because I heard that when you
used to put on productions for your high
school he would come and support you and
folks would be losing their mind cuz you
were at the height of it and the first
time I directed a play he came and it
was right I think after speed and
someone ran downstairs when like your
brother's here and I think they've heard
him because it was also a boarding
school and it was actually he was
leaning down but someone thought that
actually what your challenge was so this
drama revolves around like a brother
who's a police officer who is facing
this ethical dilemma to see like how he
would help his brother in prison between
the two of you who is more likely to
bail the other one out of trouble I'm
Way more organized but I still might get
the job I think you would actually you
know what you yes that's true but I
wouldn't plan it really well but you
would execute no you know what I'd get
caught and you wouldn't oh that's true I
can't bail you out of jail yeah you tell
me because I would get carpet if you did
it you wouldn't get caught such a fun
dynamic destruction business directors
act in producing financing creative
development and then call that a boss
yeah
[Music]